supongamos que tenemos dos rectas déjame
pintar por aquí una de las rectas y por
acá la otra ahí tenemos dos rectas voy a
pintar así flechitas para indicar que
las rectas siguen hacia esas direcciones
y ahora imagínate que conocemos la
medida de este ángulo de acá y sabemos
que vale 7 x 182 7 x +
182 y que sabemos que la medida del otro
lado de este ángulo de acá es igual a 9
x 9 x + 194 bueno con esta información
será posible saber cuánto mide cada uno
de estos dos ángulos te sugiero detener
el vídeo y pensarlo por tu cuenta
ahorita ya vamos a empezar con la
solución bueno lo primero que observamos
es que estos dos son ángulos opuestos
por este vértice de acá y entonces miden
lo mismo eso lo que nos da es una
ecuación verdad nos dice que 9 x 194 9 x
más 194 es igual a 7 x más 182 es igual
a 7 x
+ 182 y a partir de esta ecuación
podemos despejar x para después calcular
el valor de estos ángulos vamos a
hacerlo para eso tendríamos que restar
7x de ambos lados lo que voy a hacer es
es pasar las x del lado izquierdo
entonces restó 7x acá y restó 7x acá y
lo que voy a hacer es pasarlas las
constantes del lado derecho de modo que
tengo que restar 194 para que de este
lado se cancele pero acá también restó
194 para preservar la igualdad vale
entonces al realizar la resta esto se
cancela esto se cancela y nos queda 9 x
menos 7 x es decir 2 x 2 x es igual a
182 menos 194 a ver cuánto es esos 194
menos 182 es 12 pero el menos lo tiene
el 194 entonces sería menos 12 menos 12
ya le estamos restando el número más
grande al número más pequeño y de aquí
simplemente dividimos entre 2
de ambos lados entre dos aquí entre dos
acá y nos queda que x es igual a menos 6
s igual queda un poco feo es igual a
menos 6 vale 2 entre 2 se cancela menos
12 entre 2 es menos 6 y ya con el valor
de x lo que podemos hacer es substituir
aquí para ver cuánto mide este ángulo
tendríamos que mide a ver 7 x menos 6 es
menos 42
+ 182 182 42 es igual a 140 entonces el
ángulo sería igual a 140 y podemos
verificarlo del otro lado también aquí
sería 9 x menos 69 x menos 6 es menos 54
menos 54 más 194 que también es igual a
140 entonces la medida de cada uno de
estos dos ángulos que es la misma es de
140 grados